[Music]
along with all the other
responsibilities of parenthood mom's
often look to inspire their kids to
start reading books but one woman
realized that busy mothers themselves
could use some encouragement to pick up
and read books of their own that is the
founding principle of her increasingly
popular podcast which has featured more
than 300 authors including 83 New York
Times bestsellers and with a title that
says it all
hey I'm Scipio and I'm the creator and
host of the podcast moms don't have time
to read books you heard correctly moms
don't have time to read books a podcast
led by this mother of four I'd like use
the book it's like look at all the dog
eared up here all the pages proving
otherwise that's a catchy title but moms
are finding time to read books moms do
find time to read books sometimes a lot
of mom said oh my gosh you've inspired
me to read again there's just so much
else competing for our time and
attention but there's something about
reading it's so fundamental to being
human it certainly is for zippy Owens
and always has been a lover of books and
their authors even as a kid which led to
a unique list of childhood idols when I
was a little girl I used to write
letters
my mom would help me go to the back of
the books and find the publisher address
and I would write letters to the author
and she would held that for me when I
was 11 years old I went to the plaza for
tea with this author who shares the name
with me zippy O'Neal fan mail wasn't all
that Owens wrote I've been writing my
whole life since I was nine years old
and my grandfather published a little
miniature book of my stories it
published an essay in seventeen when I
was 16 years old I loved writing I've
written several books that have not been
published one book that I co-wrote that
was published I'd love to write what do
I do it all the time yeah writing is how
I sort out the craziness in my mind the
essays that I write I know can help
other people I lost my best friend over
9/11 she was my college roommate and
best friend and I immediately wrote
about it for my business school paper
and I remember my classmates saying like
how could you do that you just like put
yourself out there like it didn't even
occur to me not to write that but I
think that the
things that I like to share are things
that everybody is thinking and feeling
which brings us back to the podcast how
is food medicine
oh I'm obsessed I do think food as
medicine the title was originally pegged
for a compilation of essays on parenting
but a friend and fellow author nudged
Owens in a different direction she said
you should start a podcast and I was
like what's a podcast you didn't even
know a podcast what not really I
literally went home and my husband Kyle
and I sat on the couch we were like
where is the podcast button how do you
podcast I don't understand what this is
so we found the podcast button I started
listening to a lot of other ones I
googled everything turns out it was
gonna be really easy not expensive
low-risk so I thought I don't know I
guess I'll try it
Owens turn to the familiar for the focus
of her podcast books
more specifically authors I've had on a
range of authors from Anne Lamott
Meg Wolitzer Jennifer whiner Evangeline
Lilly who wrote a children's book series
and was on lost
so she's even had her own father as a
guest billionaire Stephen Schwarzman who
runs the world's largest private equity
firm hi thanks so much for doing this
one of the first people I interviewed
was Andre Agassi who wrote the book open
which was one of my favorite books you
weren't at this point an experienced
podcaster I didn't know what I was doing
but again I was just trying to talk to
him I really had things I wanted to know
about him and Tana's in his life and the
writing I did it on the phone but I was
drenched in sweat like so nervous asking
him all these questions how did you find
coaching versus playing it was
interesting you know it's when I played
I never felt pressure at all it was
never about pressure it was I felt
stress I remember running downstairs
after and being like I did it
almost two years later Owens has
hundreds of podcasts under her belt she
now tapes most of her interviews in this
home library studio helping create a
comfortable and intimate space there are
a lot of book podcasts out there there
are a lot of people doing interviews out
there
what's different about your podcast I'm
not afraid to ask about what I really
want to know I'm legitimately interested
which I think people can tell I'm like
get really excited and I'm passionate
about it her podcast guests would agree
but say that's not all I mean first of
all I love the name of her abroad guys
because it's kind of counterintuitive
like moms don't have time to read and it
you're listening to the podcast and
you're gonna read and hopefully you're
gonna read the book Tiffany Shlain is
the author of 24 6 a book about taking a
break from technology zippy is super
curious and interested in passionate and
I think you can see it in everything she
does Michelle Phil gates the editor of
what my mother and I don't talk about I
had been hearing about her podcasts for
a while and was so excited when she
invited me to be on why because she's
someone who is a real literary citizen
she connects readers with writers from
book fairs to live author events moms
don't have time to read books has built
an offline community to go along with
its online footprint her podcast is
crucial for allowing for curation in an
age where we are inundated with books
for Owens it's even more than that after
her divorce she says reading and her
podcast became another type of therapy
I went from full time mom to suddenly
having these blocks of times without my
kids which was really painful
for me and a very hard adjustment and I
had this therapist once who said you
know if you have a book you'll never be
lonely and I wasn't lonely I had my
husband and lots of friends and I'm very
lucky my family but it's really hard so
being able to have something else to
throw myself into was therapeutic for me
do you think that's why you want to
share that with so many other people
because it was something that helped you
yes I mean I feel like books have helped
me through so much sometimes just the
right book at the right time can can
change your life and make you feel less
alone I think that's part of why I love
doing this the ones to thank for that
authors authors are such rock stars I
mean really they're all I feel doing
such a sir
to all of us they're spending their
lives in their time sitting alone
usually writing to help other people or
to produce stories that will transport
people and entertain people
and I think they should get there do you
know the thing that was so unique is
this is not about money for she's
fortunate in that way but this is a
passion project she just wants to put
books in people's hands and get people
reading and by talking to these authors
and getting to know them in the podcast
she's opening people's minds about oh I
liked that person maybe I'll try their
book authors are rock stars and they so
often do not get the attention they
deserve so good on anyone bringing in
that I know how much Jeff loves to read
yeah and read books in particular
reviewer you were itching I know you
insist I mean you're saying a couple
dart apart there's a couple amazing I
did author talk a few years ago on the
website but I mean there's a couple of
great quotes in there right it's a one
is Reading Is Fundamental it is just
fundamental to human existence and
writing she says is how I sort out my
mind yeah so many of us do a really
really nice intimate conversation thanks
Dana great stuffing